[Music]
foreign
this ought to work well
so why are we here exactly heard carrie
got himself a buck a mansion here
done well where'd you hear anything
about carrie
in and about town scream sheets are full
of [ __ ] about it
oh right you weren't around
your big night out so what want to pay
him a visit
yep seems as good a time as any
know what they're writing about him he's
depressed attempted suicide
what really worried he wants to hurt
himself who knows
either way could give him some pointers
meaning you want to go in person
gotta hand you the reins again yes
behave myself last time did i i think i
warrant another furlough for
good behavior
okay but i want to know what you plan to
do
nothing stupid i promise just want to
see how he's doing
how you plan to tell him it's you could
be dealing with some real personal [ __ ]
right now
might not be the best time to mess with
his head v care was always dealing with
personal [ __ ]
that's why in spite of everything else
we got along
don't worry i'll play it by ear
sensitively
first things first we gotta get into
that house
okay just let me know when you want to
take the wheel
fortunately after their rescue and
following a brief rest for technical
evaluation
the miners were able to immediately
return to work
moving from below the earth to above it
militech has announced plans to
establish a new colony on the red planet
the proposed base will be separated into
three
areas industrial scientific and
residential
ten residential modules are already
available for purchase
at a starting rate of 100 million euro
dollars
a hefty price yes but can you truly put
a price on your security
in new mexico and oklahoma a new bout of
unrest has erupted in the wake of
suicide
at nus basics
[Music]
foreign
hmm
fugly is seafood barf
hope it was expensive at least
something's got to justify this
level of tacky
wicked bad collection well now i am
impressed
played a few of these myself back in our
samurai days
looks like he's showering alone too
good thing believe me okay leave the
rest to me i'll get him out of there
drop one of misty special pills let's go
okay
ah feels so much better
now let's see what you're up for show in
which you're actually strummable
[Music]
who the [ __ ]
keep playing all right
carrie
no
no that's some [ __ ] joke
hang on what did silverham tell me
before he died
told you to leave samurai go your own
way
clearly i was right as i often am
johnny [ __ ] silverhead
[ __ ] i mean how
surprise [ __ ]
okay weren't expecting me i get it
oh [ __ ] contraire been waiting 50
years to do that
see it changed a bit sporting a new
style trying to stay
hip
not looking all bad yourself either
[ __ ] johnny oh yeah you need a drink
all right come on tell me
why do you look like a small-time
kleptopunk from the afterlife
long as you tell me what you got in your
throat
always did complain i couldn't carry a
tune nice place
ain't seen much of it yet
moved in after the fourth album came out
all sold well apparently
[ __ ] you johnny don't even start
who'd you sign with [ __ ]
with arasaka warnings i record at their
studio
then evenings yuri pops over for a
little neighborly cookout
hmm and who'd you really sign with
msm records another pillar of society
come on sit down with me tell me where
you've been all this time
steal yourself for a long story
i just really want it to be tragic
sad is all [ __ ] over all those years
cause if i hear you spent them with the
nomads
open road winning your hair more
cool and relaxed in orbit and now you've
just popped by the [ __ ] all over my life
well i'ma lose my damn mind
listen judge for yourself
oh [ __ ] remember the one damn time
henry showed up sober and clean as a
whistle uh-huh
and played absolute tripe at least danny
was happy
never did get what denny saw on that guy
i mean smart in that one maybe too
smart for the company she kept nah danny
always went for
losers incapable of addressing
themselves
oh hank was perfect half a brain and
high all the time
she got to rescue him over and over
again why'd she never try and fix me
would i have to get in line that's why
stuff about you being depressed it true
nope promo strategy
suicide attempts too think putting a
bullet through your skull will help your
sails
didn't work for you nobody remember
samurai
now you're just butt hurt because i
manage fine without you
[ __ ] me got no answer to that
still in touch with the gang just nance
changed her name to bess isis
works for n54 news
good track down denny and henry if you
want
maybe get together you know
jam or something
best isis damn nance really went for it
though all i hear is part-time stripper
with a thing for ancient egypt
shame you died sure she would have
welcomed your input
how she in general besides having
nothing to do with music
could ask her yourself
you want to bring samurai back
nah no could do one gig
play some dive where nobody plays us
i mean got my reputation to think about
all right let's do it [ __ ] yeah
okay send you nancy's number in a sec
i'll go after henry and danny hmm i'm
not there
figure it out with v sure uh
you two get along not lately no
we don't have much of a choice though
how am i
johnny you okay
no ah so you must be v
johnny mentioned something like this
might happen
you two have fun at least
that a hint of disapproval i hear
just sit tight for a bit rest
don't worry about a thing
the hell is this concert thing did you
hear that
get sharper as the pills wear off so
want to see samurai live probably won't
get another chance
what if this ends up like the rogue
thing one big letdown
nah this is different kerry needs this
concert
okay calling nancy
[ __ ] yeah nice
nancy uh i mean the best
best isis no this is her underpaid
under appreciated assistant steven
n54 news how can i help
want to talk to bess she's not here
calling from carrie uridine's residence
cool
but best still isn't here she was
supposed to be back two days ago went to
the totem towers to shoot some stuff
story on maelstrom call back next week
or just watch the news
anything happens to her i'll be the
first to cover it
got a bad feeling v i think we better